gilbert collard élus du rassemblement
bleus marines proche de marine le pen
député du gard est l'invité de preuves
par 3 bonsoir bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous pour ce rendez-vous de public
sénat avec l' agence france-presse
trois questions chacune donc des parties
vous invitera à répondre à une grande
question
gilbert collard première à propos du
chômage est ce que françois hollande a
gagné son pari vous nous le dira et
deuxième question la république est elle
en danger
comme le dit le grand maître du grand
orient de france alors que manuel valls
redoute qu'elle tombe il l'a dit hier
soir entre les mauvaises mains de
l'extrême droite vous répondrez à
déborah claude de l' agence
france-presse et puis troisième question
christiane taubira au coeur de bien des
polémiques est elle une accusés ou une
victime
vous l'aurez vous le dirai tout à
l'heure à les questions là sur la
sécurité sur la justice seront abordés
par perrine tarneaud donc dans la
troisième partie de cette émission une
baisse de 0,7 pour cent le mois dernier
du jamais vu depuis huit ans ce recul de
chômage on le doit aux fruits de nos
réformes c'est ce que dit en tous les
cas aujourd'hui le gouvernement et
notamment le premier ministre
est-ce que selon vous françois hollande
va gagner son pari sur l'inversion de la
courbe bon côté il va tout faire pour
essayer de nous faire accroire que la
courbe du chômage baisse mais d'abord si
on intègre les dom on arrive à 0,6 pour
cent c'est déjà un correctif important
ensuite il n'est concerné dans cette
baisse que la catégorie 1 ier les
déconvenues ces serres voilà quand même
à une tendance de fond moi j'aimerais
mais non je crois que j'y crois pas
parce que bon quand vous pensez quand on
a un million de chômeurs de plus sur
trois ans bon et puis
on n'a aucune croissance faudrait qu'on
arrive à une croissance de 5% pour qu'on
puisse avoir une espérance de régression
du chômage on en est hélas
malheureusement loin parce que je vous
le dis franchement même si c'était au
bénéfice de françois hollande
j'en serais tellement heureux pour mes
compatriotes que je dirais c'est bien
mais malheureusement plus là tout
l'apport des d'emploi d'état les emplois
aidés bon on sait c'est une embellie de
circonstance et malheureusement dans ce
contexte et après vos critiques ou
considéré que françois hollande sera
légitime à se présenter à aller au
combat en 2017 puisqu'il avait dit qu'il
lit et sa candidature nouvelle à la
baisse du chômage alors si c'est si
c'est sur cette baisse du chômage là
qu'il se considère comme comme adoubé
par l'économie il a désormais planer
2016 à la bombe en recul du chômage donc
on peut attendre mais toute façon moi je
ne peu m'importe qui sera le candidat
des socialistes à venir
ça c'est leur problème ils ont fait
sortir ou leur primaire françois
hollande
tout peut arriver toutes les surprises
peuvent nous arriver avec les primaires
du ps sur le front du chômage est ce que
vous réclamez par exemple une refonte du
code du travail à moi alors là je suis
peu en tant que juriste pas du tout
spécialiste du droit peu de mal mais
quand même bon ayant ayant eu l'occasion
à maintes reprises de fréquenter ces
juridictions
je considère qu'on ne peut plus au delà
des partis politiques franchement
travailler dans un cadre du travail
aussi compliqué aussi abscons aussi
contraignant on peut plus françois
hollande aujourd'hui a rendu un hommage
républicain se sont movie cube de
l'accident en gironde on va l'écouter et
puis vous allez nous donner votre avis
personne ne peut comprendre que des
personnalités si belle puisse
disparaître brutalement par une cruelle
matinée d'octobre personne n'est préparé
à une telle épreuve
voilà pourquoi nous vous devons la
solidarité et c'est le pays tout entier
la france que je représente en se joue
auprès de vous qui s'est trouvée
bouleversée par cette catastrophe
tout simplement parce qu'elles pouvaient
nous concerner tous chacun d'entre nous
est ce que vous êtes touché d'entendre
évoqué donc le pays tout entier
oh non je vous le ver fait par cette
catastrophe franchement oui non non je a
écouté les fêtes le jeu wii non laissez
moi parler franchement je suis très
touché par le malheur de tout d'abord
qui ne le serait pas à vendre mais je
trouve françois hollande obscène
obscènes et pour une fois je vais faire
mienne une phrase de cohn-bendit c'est
sans les jeux olympiques de la
compassion at il dit
il a raison bon que que la nation
s'émeuvent que d'accord mais le
président de la république qui va nous
vendre qui va nous vendre alors que
visiblement bon cette espèce de 2,2
discours qui se veut historique qui est
un discours d'estrade qua non mais dire
c'est pas comme ça qu'on rend hommage
aux morts d'hier en ciel en son absence
mais les familles se sont dit touché 800
mais alors chaque fois qu'il va y avoir
un drame arrive à se déplacer maintenant
voilà bon si demain il ya un drame qui
frappe 15 personnes il va y être obligé
d'y aller dire que et puis si un jour il
ya un drame est là ce qui est plus
important il va encore y aller et on va
plus savoir à quel moment l'hommage
républicain est vraiment de l'ordre de
l'expression de la nation ou de la
recherche d'une expression d'un
président de la république qui luttent
contre son info ni électorale voilà
c'est encore une fois je prends les
risques de mon propos je vous assure la
de la compassion j'en ai et je pense que
tous ici on sait ce que c'est que de
perdre un être quand même à le rôle du
chef de l'ailé mais le chef de l'état
qui s'en va
dans ces circonstances ex discours ont
plus que je trouve malheureux mois
inadaptée quoi oui mais comme l'a dit tu
as raison c'est sans les jeux olympiques
de la compassion et plus loin en parlant
d' obscénité with you feel it et oui je
le dis parce que l' obscénité c'est ce
qui choque c'est ce qui c'est obscène de
d'entendre un chef de l'état
dans des circonstances aussi dramatiques
aussi aussi douloureuse se placer voilà
ça me gène le gène rien dire aussi aux
familles des victimes que l'etat sera là
pour que elles connaissent la vérité
mais c'est la police mais il faut que le
patronat et monsieur il faut que le
président de la république se déplace
dans un pays de droit où il ya des juges
des juges d'instruction pour dire aux
familles on vous donnera la vérité
attendait maintenant quel pays on est la
vérité c'est un droit on n'y a droit au
nom de la fonction de la justice au nom
de la loi avec un l majuscule
on n'a pas besoin d'un président de la
république pour nous dire qu'on
connaîtra la vérité
enfin quand même sinon ça veut dire que
la justice ne fonctionne que si le
président de la république lui donne
l'ordre de fonctionner non non je fais
confiance aux juges alors samuel vals
maintenant il a présenté hier des
mesures vous l'avez entendu en faveur de
la mixité sociale d'autre qui vise à
lutter contre les discriminations et ce
qu'il appelait l'apartheid social
territorial éthique de presse que vous
approuvez cette dernière formule non
nous ont d'abord aller emprunter un
univers
que que nous connaissons qui a été
effroyable horrible avec toute une
législation d'apartheid enfin je veux
dire que c'est quand même dramatique que
qu'un homme politique utilise un mot qui
correspond à une catégorie juridique
d'humiliation de ségrégation de
minoration pour pour pour caractériser
un état qui est d'abord un état souvent
de non droit et dans lequel je parle de
l'état des banlieues on a mis beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent
on a fait beaucoup pour les banlieues
bon c'est un échec parce qu'on a laissé
s'implanter une sous culture et la
raison donc de décider de mesures
complémentaires et est grande entre ça
il serait temps d'accord et oui il va
lutter jusqu'à temps jusqu'en 2018 quand
tu seras plus là il serait temps entre
nous mais moi je crois qu est-ce que
vous prendriez vous comme une première
mesure par exemple
mais au jeu à la première à la d'abord
je sais comme tous les criminologues le
savent je rappelle que toutes les études
sur les banlieues ont d'abord concerné
le brésil c'est un dénommé de sabots je
crois qui est un grand criminel au café
des études très précises sur les favelas
la première chose à faire c'est de ne
pas laisser s'installer les gangs
les groupes donc il faut pas hésiter à y
aller non mais on y va on y va s'il faut
envoyer parce qu'il ya des difficultés y
pénétrer l'armée on envoie l'armée
on n'a pas d'états de peur à avoir c'est
le territoire français il ya des
familles qui sont terrorisés qui osent
plus sortir que celui broncher parce que
ces quartiers centre les mains de gangs
françois hollande et angela merkel
évoque aujourd'hui en ce moment même à
l'élysée le sort des réfugiés également
la sécu la question syrienne
les réfugiés sont on l'a appris
aujourd'hui 700 milles depuis le mois de
janvier avoir traversé la méditerranée
comment contenir selon vous la situation
gilbert collard et moi je vais d'abord
d'abord en ans en évitant un de
s'embarquer dans des conflits où on ne
fait qu'attiser les difficultés je veux
dire que s'il y avait encore
kadhafi savait encore saddam hussein qui
avait encore tous ces tyrans odieux
qu'on déteste bachar el assad
oui oui oui oui oui et des dieux qu'on
déteste mais dont on a besoin voilà il
faut la politique savez si vous voulez
faire du scoutisme vous remettez vos
culottes courtes et vous allez non mais
vous allez dans les camps de scouts
s'ils voulaient faire de la politique
mais vous avez le courage de dire je
préfère cette solution parce que elle
est moins dramatique qu'une autre moi je
préfère bachar el-assad à l'état
islamique voilà et malheureusement
l'état islamique chez vous connaissez la
représentation diplomatique de l'état
islamique ou non bon vous connaissez la
représentation islamique de l'état dont
bachar al assad est le président oui bon
voilà là on sait où s'adresser
on a une représentation diplomatique ça
fait quand même des différences
notamment est ce que vous faites plus
confiance aujourd'hui à vladimir poutine
pour nous débarrasser des diabétiques
oui oui parce que le plus confiance à
lui qu'à barack obama c'était ma
question et barack obama il est
maintenant il est maintenant sur le
point du départ et puis il ya les
élections qui qui qui qui ce qui se
dessine donc il est plus il est plus en
mesure de prendre malheureusement
d'où la gravité du quinquennat entre
nous il est plus en mesure de prendre
des décisions il un peu comme françois
hollande qui maintenant qui maintenant
de là plus qu'une idée en tête c'est
essayer de se faire réélire alors on
voudrait vous interroger sur un autre
sujet d'actualité qui n'a rien à voir
c'est la situation dans la sphère qu'on
a appelé air cocaïne oui ces deux
pilotes qui ont donc quitté le pays qui
ont réussi à être exfiltré ou à fuir
ils ont en tous les cas aujourd'hui
donner une conférence de presse ils ont
réussi à partir à quitter le pays
mais ils sont reste aujourd'hui très
discret sur la façon qu'ils ont utilisés
pour pour s'en aller et c'est écouter
maître dupond-moretti qui a répondu à
leur place sur cette question on a même
des éléments qui permet de dire que ce
sont des initiatives personnelles c'est
pas la peine de fantasmer c'est pas une
équipe barbouzardes qui ont été payés
par l'état français
c'est pas ça l'histoire ne vous méprenez
pas du tout ce sont des initiatives
personnelles alors des initiatives
personnelles on parle quand même de la
présence effective un prêt de ses
pilotes de certains élus et notamment du
député européen international
aymeric chauprade est ce que vous
trouvez ça normal non mais attendez moi
je
je vous parle d'une question que je
connais bien puisque j'ai été amené à
m'occuper en tant qu'avocat de deux
affaires en république dominicaine aller
les fameuses douceur les deux soeurs
dont l'une se prénommait sahara et puis
un jeune français bon franchement quand
on est sorti de la prison là bas on n'a
pas besoin de la dgse des services
secrets pour avoir des faux papiers et
partir c'est très facile et n'importe
quelle initiative personnelle un peu
organisée avec de l'argent peut vous
permettre de quitter le territoire donné
raison d'avoir pris à moi
personnellement je n'aurais pas une très
grande confiance
vu ce que j'ai vu dans la justice de la
république dominicaine
bon donc ils sont venus en france ils
ont affaire à des juges français
ils ont à répondre dans le cadre de
l'instruction qui conduites par des
juges français des faits qu'on leur
reproche
et je pense qu'ils ont beaucoup plus à
attendre de la justice française que de
la justice de la république dominicaine
maintenant chauprade je n'imagine pas en
cascadeur en espion en tentant
flingueurs je sais qu'à l'époque où je
m'occupais des affaires il était à
l'ambassade de france et qu'il avait un
rôle diplomatique
mais je n'imagine vraiment pas sauter à
la perche faire du kung fu 1 vous pouvez
simple que ça pour fuir le pays et sur
les goûts du nikkei oui aujourd'hui la
république dominicaine annonce qu'elle
va émettre un mandat d'arrêt
international
un ouh c'est la monnaie le jeu demandé
l'arrestation d'aider des pilotes est ce
qu'il faut satisfaire cette demande et
il faudra leur il faut d'abord voir
clairement joué j'ai pu en mémoire un
franchement la convention qui lie la
france
à la république dominicaine parce que
tout se joue dans la convention et je ne
sais pas s'il est prévu que la
république dominicaine puisse dénoncer
des faits délictueux à la france si
c'est prévu dans la convention elle peut
le faire et peut y avoir des poursuites
ici
bon mais je ne le de mémoire deux
mémoires chalet tromper je ne crois pas
très bien en revanche il est un con il
est impossible que les ressortissants
français soient renvoyés en république
dominicaine dominicaine très bien alors
on va évoquer bientôt les élections à
venir mais avant cela j'aimerais savoir
si vous êtes pour que la france ratifié
la charte européenne des langues
régionales puisque le sénat on a débattu
aujourd'hui elle s'apprête à rejeter
cette perspective ben moi que tu es
d'abord j'aimerais j'aimerais qu'on
enseigne bien le français et break le
français ne devienne pas une langue
régionale
d'abord et c'est pas rien quand on voit
le nombre de mots dont dispose chaque
français quand on lit toutes les études
faites par monsieur bentolila bon qui
quand même
l'inde est l'un des spécialistes de la
langue
on est inquiet sur le devenir de notre
langue française à partir du moment où
elle est installée ou à les pérenniser
où elle est défendue
j'ai vraiment de la sympathie mois pour
les langues régionales oui je le
confesse et je trouve agréable
heureusement tout le monde dit ça mais
la question c'est est ce qu ont ratifié
la charte euros par équipe moi je le
ratifierait pas moi je n'engage que
c'est que j'ai un électron libre un peu
vous êtes un électron libre un accord
très bien alors il fallait la prendre
vous allez répondre en électron libre à
la deuxième question de preuves par 3
gilbert collard avec deborah claude de
l' agence france-presse
qui va nous rejoindre et la question est
celle ci la république est elle en
danger cet avertissement a été lancé
notamment vous l'avez lu dans le journal
du dimanche par le grand maître du grand
orient de france david keller tu
considères que l'on est aujourd'hui en
france en train de dérouler le tapis
rouge au front national alors que manuel
valls écouté hier soir l'hôtel de ville
de paris
dans un discours sur la laïcité a dit le
danger selon lui de l'extrême droite
je ne veux pas que l'extrême droite
entre par effraction dans le destin de
la france qu'elle vienne
elle qui se dit maintenant républicaine
allons bon
alors que toute son histoire de père en
fils ou de grand père en petites filles
montrent le contraire qu'elle a toujours
combattu la république
je ne veux pas que l'extrême droite
viennent saccager ce que nous ont laissé
les clemenceau les jaurès mais aussi de
gaulle voilà des bras claude la question
donc ce que l'art est ce que vous êtes
un cinquième est ce que vous êtes un
saccage heure de l'est de jaurès et de
clemenceau comme bien de l'entendre je
crois pas pourquoi plutôt que celui qui
qui saccagent jaurès et clemenceau c'est
surtout que les morceaux parce qu'il
s'en réclament beaucoup c'est monsieur
c'est monsieur valls qui ignore tout
mais tout de l'histoire de france et de
la troisième république et de la
quatrième république et de la vème
république
alors il parle de l'extrême droite qui
arriverait par effraction mais vous avez
vu que d'abord on appartenait à
l'extrême droite et qu'ensuite on
voulait prendre le pouvoir par
effraction mais il se rend pas compte
des mots qu'ils emploient
il a eu des mots très très fort ils
l'ont mis dans nos maisons dit
l'empereur sith et les dangers des
notaires parce que ces gens changent
d'andré il a pris du mot effraction mais
je suis super franchement il faut qu'il
prenne de la deûle à la tisane ou serez
l'effraction on va se présenter à des
élections le peuple va voter et si on a
les suffrages pour nous il n'y a pas
d'effraction sur les autres sur les
autres
non mais vous n'êtes pas d'accord sur le
terrain youri est gravé un terme qui a
parfois été employée de l'événement et
l'extrême droite il avait l'extension
aux portes et de pouvoir un navet des
élections sans doute également à la
présidentielle on met les fractions
ménages est en écoute et je suis désolé
moi je veux bien tout supporter mais il
est premier ministre on doit quand même
le créditer d'un minimum de maîtrise du
vocabulaire un minimum les fractions ou
qui sera pour vous et des rappels et
s'est fracturé ses forces et s'est brisé
c'est agir par force
à quel moment on a fait preuve d' action
de force nous à quel moment à quel
moment on n'a pas respecté le suffrage à
quel moment la dépression si l'on
comprend bien c'est bousculer
si on écoute le passé les virées s'est
bousculé les valeurs de la république
alors que ce sens et à quel moment s'il
était là je dirais mais à quel moment
nous avons nous avons maltraiter les
valeurs de la république
à quel moment moi députés qu'ils aient
voté la suppression du délit de
solidarité qui demande qu'on soumette le
parquet une récusation qui qui est
présenté des propositions de loi
fondamentalement démocratique notamment
sur la révocation du président de la
république sur le référendum à quel
moment toute ma vie moi je me suis battu
pour les valeurs républicaines sais pas
c'est pas lui qui n'a été qu'un
fonctionnaire de la politique toute sa
vie parce que qu'est-ce qu'il a fait
d'autre que d'être que d'être dans un
syndicat d'étudiants et là il a fait que
de la petite politique de petits partis
toute sa vie qu'est ce qu'il apporte
comme preuve de son attachement à la
république
il se promène tout le temps et manuel
valls avec sa valeur sa valise à valeurs
républicaines
d'autres d'autres qui se promène avec
une grosse valise républicaine comme le
grand maître du grand orient de france
monsieur keller qui ce week-end a fait
une interview assez forte également en
dix ans la république est en danger
moi même je vais aller faire de la
pédagogie dans le forez qu'est ce que ça
vous inspire
ils représentent rien c'est quoi le
grand orient la grande loge de france il
ya la grande loge nationale de france il
ya le grand orient qui est le bras armé
dans la maçonnerie du parti socialiste
quand on est socialiste on est au grand
orient
il n'y a pas que cette obédience ne
représente rien c'est quoi le grand
orient aujourd'hui c'est quelque part le
prolongement maçonnique du parti
socialiste mais mais il peut on entre
dans les querelles au sein de la
franc-maçonnerie oui parler aussi
d'expérience de paris engagement et moi
j'étais en franc maçonnerie qui n'était
pas encore le le le vénérable du grand
orient bon monsieur qu'elle est je
connaissais même pas son nom du rsa
représente qu'il ait eu ça fait 3 et la
trois mandats oui vous vous connaissiez
sont non franchement honnêtement
bon on a écouté nous connaît non mais on
est on essaie on essaie de jouer le jeu
franchement là vous connaissez son nom
est ce que c'est un bon vous êtes un
ennemi de la révolution mais sur le fond
parce que son bébé mais ac large du
public je t'aime j'ai toute ma vie moi
défendu les valeurs républicaines et
j'ai continué à les défendre
il faut être il faudrait un faux procès
mais qu'il est écouté
donnez moi un acte voilà citez moi un
acte qui permettrait de dire qu'on a
porté atteinte aux valeurs vous avez
entendu le premier ministre s'il veut le
front national dans la lignée de
l'extrême droite en france nommé je
récuse les valeurs de la république pour
reprendre les arguments
bon alors c'était l'argument historique
ça bon alors voudrez je voudrais qu'il
cite un acte dans l'histoire récente qui
permettrait de dire vous allez porter
atteinte aux valeurs de la république
un acte maintenant je vous rappelle
quand même que l'histoire du parti
communiste elle est particulièrement
dramatique du point de vue des valeurs
de la république
je vous rappelle que que georges
marchais se félicite et qu'on éradique
est un foyer de maliens qu'il trouvait
qu'il y avait trop d'immigrés en france
je vous rappelle que duclos à l'époque
du reste
il y avait laurent le père qui était au
comité directeur
traité les homosexuels de fou hehy
demandé qu'on les internes
bon il y avait sali no sag la mention je
reste sur l'histoire du front national
manifestement vous avez entendu premier
ministre il a rappelé mary coordination
également mais du père et de la fille de
jean marie le pen qui on se souvient a
eu le même type de condamnation vous le
sonos met d'accord l'eau certains de ses
propos il pas le détail mais qui pas le
moi je le détail j'ai toujours condamné
maintenant est ce que vous considérez
que l'expression de jean marie le pen
est une atteinte qui met en péril le
fonctionnement de la démocratie mais il
était exclu de votre voilà non mais est
ce que moi je n'adhérais pas moi j'adore
j'adore mais moi je suis tout à fait
solidaire à 100% mais j'aime bien qu'on
ait un dialogue parce que c'est la cie
du dialogue que connaît l'authenticité
bon est-ce que les propos de jean marie
le pen que je condamne que marine le pen
dans son livre à contre flots a condamné
très tôt elle n'était pas encore en
politique il faudrait le lire ce livre
est ce que vous considérez que ces
propos portent atteinte à la république
est-ce que ça a mis en péril la
démocratie parce que rien jamais ne vous
êtes gênés dans les discours nouveaux
amis mais il ya des choix mais il ya des
choses qui me gêne dans les discours des
cas monsieur valls par exemple trouve
qu'à repasser de noir sur la place d'un
marché dans sa ville
ça me choque ça me choque bien
évidemment de la même manière que
lorsque certaines personnes de mon
mouvement qui aiment des propos déplacés
ça me choque et je le dis de la même
manière que lorsque un responsable de
l'ump
comparé les manifestants à des
descendants d'esclaves ça me choque
bon mais est ce que ça veut dire pour
autant que monsieur valls quand il tombe
qui a pas assez de blancs portent
atteinte aux valeurs de la république ou
le député qui trouvent que les
manifestants ressemble rappel par dont
les descendants d'esclaves
est ce qu'à ce moment là ils portent
atteinte aux valeurs de la république je
crois pas ils disent des conneries
donc c'est simplement dans une
poule c à la mesure de la ils ont ils
ont une extraordinaire colite
républicaine une collègue républicaine
oui alors le député ps malek boutih que
vous connaissez ni lui alors il ne voit
pas comment marine le pen pourrait ne
pas gagner la présidentielle pour vous
aussi s'est jouée d'avancé
en politique rien n'est joué d'avancé
mais je pense qu'à l'heure actuelle
l'état dans lequel se trouve la france
appelle aux pouvoirs le courage la
lucidité et la détermination
aucun de nos hommes politiques
aujourd'hui à l'exception de marine le
pen
non ce courage cette détermination alors
joué d'avancé aux pages écouter sur les
régions oui je pense du reste moi je
n'étais pas pour qu'elles se présentent
oui j'étais sectorielle y ait des
réticents vous y avait des réticences
jeu suite au rebond
louis aliot partager une même la même
opinion que moi nous ont préféré
qu'elles se concentrent sur la
présidentielle qu'elles prennent pas le
risque de cette élection
elle a préféré y aller ce qui prouve que
ben elle avait raison et que nous on
avait tort bon il faut faire amende
honorable quand on se trompe
je pense qu'elle va être dans le
résultat mais rien n'est joué d'avancé
parce que l'ump feint les républicains
et les socialistes peuvent tout faire
pour garder le pouvoir
ils sont prêts à copuler à faire un
monstre il ce qu'ils peuvent tout faire
ils ont montré en faisant élire des
maires en votant pour des mères avec qui
se déchiraient c'était le cas à saint
gilles il entend montrer dans le gard
notamment lors des élections
départementales en faisant élire un
socialiste il se dispute à l'assemblée
ils votent les uns pour les autres bons
donc c'est très compliqué on ne sait pas
du tout comment les arrangements entre
ennemis vont finir par devenir des
arrangements entre amis
alors écoutez justement ce que répondait
jean christophe cambadélis aux
assurances de malek boutih sur 2017 on
écoute le faut jusqu'à faire du psg
pourrait gérer je suis moins sûr que lui
mais c'est une possibilité
c'est une possibilité il faut le fond
qu'il faut l'intégrer je suis moins sûr
parce que je pense qu'au fur et à mesure
que l'on s'approche de la présidentielle
le plafond de verre
se trouve posée pour le front national
c'est à dire est-ce qu'ils sont
qualifiés pour gérer ce pays
mais à un moment donné il faut aussi
intégrer cette dimension et je pense que
c'est valable plus valable dans les
régions que au niveau des
présidentielles mais c'est une
possibilité
donc monsieur cambadélis dit c'est une
possibilité effectivement d'ailleurs les
socialistes ont l'air un petit peu
embêté sur la stratégie à adopter pour
ces régionales
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire ils font
trottoir voilà je vous dise bon c'est à
dire que c'est à dire qu'ils vont
essayer de racoler de racoler les voix
de l'ump au caylar
tout est stratégique il faut il faut
donner des prétextes aux républicains de
venir soutenir les socialistes où il
faut donner des prétextes socialiste de
venir soutenir les républicains
l'habillage c'est que nous sommes la
menace finale à la fin de la démocratie
est comme ça c'est faux derche avec ce
prétexte peuvent se rassembler ce qu'une
construction rhétorique
ils sont en train de faire un montage
mais je crois qu'à l'heure actuelle
notamment chez les électeurs des
républicains ça ne prendra plus moi je
vois plein d'amis oui qui était qui
étaient aux républicains ou chez les
républicains qui me disent c'est fini en
titre en allant supporte plus qu'on nous
fasse voter pour les socialistes
on n'est pas de gauche et ses
arrangements contre nature on ne les
supporte plus le motif que me donne la
plupart des gens qui nous rejoignent
en l'espèce histoire doit plutôt
d'électeurs socialistes qui seraient
appelés à voter pour les républicains
oui mais là j'aimerais santos en ce sens
a apparemment averses peut-être où le
parti non mais regardez regardez dans le
gard par exemple pour les
départementales pour les départements
voilà bon sens sont quand même à
l'époque c'était l'ump bas ils ont fait
élire un socialiste
et oui et oui on sent seul alors
maintenant passons à vos tops votre
parti qui n'est pas encore notre parti
et quand est ce que vous allez prendre
votre carte donc si je suis apparentés
vous êtes rbm on est longtemps il faut
quand même les artes que mais là encore
il faut pas un petit point d'étape où on
examine au japon lé japon mais de là
encore faut pas prendre les gens pour
des pour des robots je suis apparenté au
front national donc je suis au front
national on n'est pas besoin de 1000
cartes les choses de prendre ma carte
mais jugé la fonction si vous voulez de
secrétaire général du rassemblement bleu
marine et ma mission c'est de recueillir
dans le mouvement des gens qui auraient
peur encore d'aller au front national
dont vous n'êtes pas utile à l'extérieur
du front voilà voilà
alors je lui ai dit en rigolant il ya
deux hypothèses où ma présence à
l'intérieur du fonds dérangerait marine
ce que je ne crois pas aux photos rouge
où ça les arrange oussalah range où je
suis beaucoup plus utile à l'extérieur
je crois et ce alors que je suis
beaucoup plus qui avec sérieux observés
je suis membre du comité directeur
suivant de la commission d'investiture
j'ai donc j'ai donc tout tous les
attributs d'un membre du front national
non mais vous aimez le langage fleuri 1
ou montré depuis le début de cette
émission au parler pourquoi c'est pas
beau et lucky copule etc on va dire vous
êtes un rabatteur alors pour marc et
voilà bravo ça vaut combien ça voilà
enfin quelqu'un qui ont plein le
français
bravo c'est ça c'est ça bravo voilà
c'est défier oui voilà c'est un
rabatteur oui et alors sensi noble
canton quant au canton rabat pour une
arme une armée qui va gagner et une
armée qui défendent pays
ça vaut le coup quelle différence près
qu'elle était le terme du reste à
l'époxy pas des rabatteurs c'était des
enrouleurs d voilà comment les appeler
lequel différence aujourd'hui faites
vous entre marine le pen et marion
maréchal-le pen parce que certains
notent des divergences idéologiques et
qui peut se retrouver d'ailleurs dans la
composition des listes
disons que disons que mario est beaucoup
plus
beaucoup plus rigide sur le plan
psychologique que marine marine est
beaucoup plus malléable sur le plan de
la discussion sur le plan des échanges
marion avec marion maréchal-le pen donc
elle est souvent assise à côté de vous à
l'assemblée vous discutez moi oui
pourquoi non mais non je l adore mario
en difficulté souvent mais vous me
demandez de vous décrire des caractères
jaloux parler de moi je vous dirais bon
il est honni clan ben voilà il bonbons
il il peut faire ci reprend il va
intervenir bon je dois aller quand elle
a quant elle a une idée elle il est
beaucoup plus difficile de la faire
changer d'avis que de faire changer
marine d'avis par l'argumentation par le
raisonnement par la discussion sur quels
points par exemple vous avez essayé de
les convaincre l'une et l'autre de
changer d'avis on est très curieux de sa
nommé nouveau lancé l'idée
j'ai lancé l'idée d'un référendum qui a
été repris bon gt gt j'ai toujours dit
pour pour pour sortir de l'euro il
fallait absolument que le peuple donne
donne son avis et que la voie du
référendum était indispensable et marine
maintenant la dila repris mais on
discute beaucoup savaient c'est pas
c'est pas monolithique chez nous on
discute on peut on peut ne pas être on
accepte de ne pas être d'accord
voilà on accepte de ne pas être d'accord
sans se fâcher j'avais une question
concernant votre mandat de parlementaire
je me souviens quand vous êtes arrivé
députés à l'assemblée vous avez dit être
député c'est le bordel être un
casse couille démocratique
est-ce que vous avez été un casse
couilles et démocratique depuis deux ans
et demi fait d'abord je me suis rendu
compte qu'il n'avait pas de couilles
donc le problème ne se posait pas
d'accord il ne vous inscrire vous
alignerez vous avez moins de tout voir
qu'un groupe nominé d'office a nommé une
embellie qui se passe tout est joué
d'avancé
je leur ai dit une fois la chambre je
leur ai dit vous êtes des faux culs j'ai
dit à la tribune est et je me rappelle
avoir précisé un jour vous serez 50 ici
bon évidemment chaque fois que je fais
une intervention je dis ce que je pense
la presse n'en parle pas donc on peut si
je sortais maintenant l'ensemble des
interventions que j'ai effectué vous
seriez étonnés de ce que j'ai pu leur
balancer
mais s'en foutent ils s'en foutent le
train continue
bon ils ont une majorité qui
réglementaire qui est disciplinaire on
peut dire ce qu'on veut on peut faire
les propositions de loi qu'on veut ce
qui compte c'est d'aller dans le sens
même si par le sens de l'intérêt général
de ce que le gouvernement veut
voilà une démocratie réglementaire
disciplinaire aujourd'hui certains de
vos collègues socialistes à l'assemblée
nationale gibert colère ont fait des
propositions pour une présidentielle
irréprochable sur le temps de parole
vous avez vu cela sur l'utilisation des
sondages également et puis sur le
système de parrainage et il suggère de
publier la liste intégrale des élus des
maires qui parraine un candidat vue est
ce que vous êtes vous n'aimez pas les
questions d'énergie que comprendre tout
à l'heure mais ce que vous êtes pour ou
contre
non je sens qu'ils sont toujours la même
logique là c'est à dire qu'ici c'est le
processus de re diabolisation qui essaie
d'installer pour arriver alors je de
pickpockets 1 au deuxième tour bon mais
c'est à dire que quand il dit il faut
les noms des parrains ça veut dire que
ils vont retravailler la diabolisation
pour gêner les éventuels parrain de
marine
cc c'est très bien conçu tout ça sauf
que vous dire que les gens maintenant
sont ouverts de 2010 d'anciennes
irréprochable c'est le sait le front
national convives
bien sûr on attendait bien sûr bien sûr
tout est fait pour parce que si on croit
quand même ce qui a été dit monsieur
hollande dans sa campagne des
présidentielles n'a pas été
irréprochable
monsieur sarkozy non plus donc c'est
plutôt
de leur propre campagne qui devrait
expirer à faire la justice concernant
les comptes vous le savez du front
national et de la campagne
présidentielle
oui bon l'histoire pour l'instant n'est
pas condamné d'accord mais les autres
non plus un acte et madame le pen ne
s'est pas rendu à un rendez vous
d'ailleurs judiciaire oui oui oui elle a
bien fait d'accord elle a bien fait de
la même manière que quand je pense qu'on
est recommandée donc ça c'est encore une
proposition de loi que j'avais fait tant
qu' on aura un syndicalisme judiciaire
aussi virulent quand on est un opposant
politique à ce syndicat manche figure
sur le mur des cons ou est-ce que vous
pouvez comprendre que d'avoir à répondre
devant un jus du syndicat si ça me
rassurerait pas alors on va parler de
justice juste offert à semer partout
voilà de justice de sécurité merci
deborah avec donc la troisième question
des preuves par 3 gilbert collard
christiane taubira au coeur donc de bien
des polémiques est elle une accusés ou
une victime vous allez répondre à
perrine tarneaud et attaqué mercredi
dernier ici même au sénat sur sa
politique pénale par le sénateur front
national daniel rachline eh bien
monsieur david david david pardon david
et il sait david rachline s'est attiré
cette réponse de la ministre de la
justice écouté ma question madame la
ministre est simple quand votre
politique pénale défendre at elle enfin
les victimes et non les bourreaux quand
mettrait fin aux remises de peine pour
tous quand les parquets ce souci se
soucieront du bien commun plutôt que
d'appliquer votre idéologie libertaire
ou d'attaqués sur vos ordres
vos adversaires politiques bref quand
serez-vous ministre de la justice et non
de l'injustice manifestement ces vérités
pour tous et impunité pour vous en prend
note de vos réelles de votre culture et
de vos pratiques on imagine ce que ça
donnerait si vous arriviez au pouvoir
mais nous allons nous battre pour que ce
soit absolument impossible alors ne
venez pas de parler ni de laxisme ni de
complaisance vis-à-vis des voyous le
laxisme monsieur le sénateur c'est de
s'accommoder d'un leader qui combine à
la fois les condamnations multiples et
les responsabilités politiques le
laxisme c'est de ne pas condamner la
violence dans vos manifestations ou en
marge mal est des journalistes ou
attaques des personnes et les jette dans
la seine
notre eau
quand marine le pen at elle été
condamnée à l'est elle allait elle est
au pire est que là mais quand caen alors
accusé aux victimes christiane taubira
fatigué fatigué les deux fatigués
asseyez vous diriez même affaibli ah oui
très affaiblie elle et de l'état cuisine
non mais moi j'ai des objectifs
elle est accusée et victime en même
temps parce que eux elle parlerait de
jean marie le pen qui avait été condamné
un pour le ban qui dirige le mouvement
elle a pas d'amalgamé de l'encens et non
je suis l'ami non on peut re pas s'ils
n'envoient pas leurs passés chez biya
mais non elle parle d'une de la
dirigeante
elle parle de marine le pen qui n'a
jamais raison d'un style non non non non
elle parle du parti s'il veut bon et
toute manière vous toute manière elle
parle d'un parti qui n'est pas dirigée
par jean marie le pen
donc c'est un usage rhétorique du passé
qui ne s'applique pas au présent
maintenant c'est un ministre
catastrophique catastrophique quoi mais
parce que n a rien compris à
l'intelligence pratique de la justice
la justice est un instrument
d'apaisement à l'origine de tout pouvoir
il ya la main de justice
c'est fondamental elle a divisé la
justice elle en a fait un instrument de
propagande idéologique et la ville 6
elle appelle à créer des divisions entre
la police la justice
il vous a quand même pas échappé que les
policiers sont allés manifester sous ses
fenêtres burnand bon quand même bon ça
veut dire qu'ils sont quand même pas
content de ce qui se passe non mais ils
sont aussi atteints un peu par un burn
out en raison des mesures de sécurité
importantes a nommé deux fois les
salades du bord d'un des attentats de
longue date
je suis désolé ils sont réalisés moyens
accordés à la police
ils sont allés se plaindre
essentiellement de la politique pénale
et après e.on a eu qui à la rue on a eu
les responsables de la détention
pénitentiaire s'est en fait si elles
sont allés se plaindre des conditions de
travail mais aussi du fait qu' il
n'avait plus les moyens juridiques
techniques
de fait régner la discipline ça c'est
pas nouveau en france avec oui mais le
problème c'est de coordonner midi c'est
la faute de christiane taubira forcément
si elle est incapable de modifier ce qui
va pas elle change
elle s'en va alors mais vous êtes
extraordinaire non je vous mais vous me
direz c'est un problème de rien les
questions engage autant que les réponses
les questions engage autant que les
réponses alors vos questions je n'ai pas
l'âge de travail
bon je les travaille si depuis qu'elle
est là ça fait trois ans maintenant elle
n'a pas été capable d'apporter la
moindre amélioration
on va continuer jusqu'à quand des
aménagements sont prévus au texte que
vous l'avez entendu sur les permissions
de sortie peu prise mais il faut les
flancs des comptes je rendais compte que
l'excellent accueil ici il faut la
conviction meyniel 25 fu chi des drains
enfin quand même avec les moyens que
l'on a quand on occupe le ministère de
la justice
avec les perspectives intellectuelle
qu'on peut avoir si on écoute les
magistrats si on écoute les
représentants des gardiens de prisons
sur l'étude il est ex pape à se rendre
compte qu'il ya un problème grave
et alors en plus la constante sur les
permissions de sortie qui évoquait un
instant à un michel grossiord est-ce
qu'il faut une nouvelle loi
est-ce qu'il faut encadrer se voir
supprimer aller jusqu'à supprimer ces
permissions de sortie quelle est votre
position vous moi je prends je moi je
pense que d'abord d'abord ce qu'une
juridiction a décidé seule une
juridiction peut le moi je pense qu'on
devrait provoquer la comparution
d'intéresser alors vous allez me dire
c'est lourd un jeu assez lourde non mais
vous avez bien regardé notamment
connaissent mieux que nous l'aura
nommément justice mais sait il s'agit de
savoir ce qu'on veut alors je vais faire
simple la série faire ça marche moins de
migrants plus d'1m eu beaucoup plus de
juges 1 et beaucoup plus de moyens pour
nos juges voilà mon choix il est fait à
ce n'est pas le vôtre bon ça c'est je
respecte votre opinion mais vous
comprenez vous me direz l'aide médicale
et l'aide médicale d'état qui coûte un
milliard j'en avais les moyens j'aurai
pour sur la ville moyens je serais pour
bon mais ça fait quand même
c'est quand même extraordinaire
d'entendre des journalistes nous dit
et on n'a pas les moyens d'avoir des
juges et on n'a pas les moyens d'avoir
des gardiens de prison et on n'a pas les
moyens de renforcer les anciennes halles
et c'est vrai et ben voila contenu mais
moi je préférerais si vous voulez que le
milliard par exemple un le milliard de
l'aide médicale d'état
on le met dans le renforcement des
mesures de contrôle attaché aux
permissions de sortie bref un milliard
ben non alors qu'il ya une personnalité
qui était là la salle collard il y avait
une personnalité qui était à votre place
la semaine dernière
c'est jean luc mélenchon et bien il a eu
des mots également très dur pour
christiane taubira il a brisé bien il
l'a accusé il a accusé le pouvoir en
général de ménage et marine le pen en
lui évitant tout une peine
d'inéligibilité dans des affaires de
justice passion savait écouter jean luc
mélenchon vous pourrez réagir un
fasciste madame taubira pourrait donner
des instructions qui permettrait par
exemple d'apurer d'une certaine manière
l'atmosphère et le niveau de ce qui se
dit dans ce pays
mais en tout cas en matière d'élections
et ne l'a jamais fait ça fera donc la
deuxième fois que le parquet qui dépend
directement du garde des sceaux propose
la relaxe à propos de madame les ménages
et politiquement absolument votre
réaction aux propos de jean les pères
mais était-ce et fascisant propos parce
que donner des ordres au garde des
sceaux va reprocher aux gardes des
sceaux de donner des ordres pour
protéger marine le pen cela voudrait
dire que on a en a mis les injustices
qui fait ce qu'il veut de ses juges
c'est possible je sais pas mais c'est
une accusation d'une gravité inouïe
ça veut dire que la magistrature serait
aux ordres servile de madame taubira et
là attention ils réagissaient notamment
la semaine dernière à la relaxe demandée
par le parquet un dans la sphère des
prières de rue qui avait été comparé à
l'occupation nazie
marine le pen on ne savait pas été
comparé à l'occupation nazie d'accord
l'occupation tout court c'est d'ouvrir
tous les catholiques mélenchon
réagissait à la relaxe demandée par le
parquet et alors voilà en fait dit
s'interroger sur l'opportunité du
calendrier de cette décision à quelques
semaines des élections régionales
le parquet qui dépend du ministère de la
justice c'est vrai que c'est un peu une
nouvelle mais moi j'étais 6 oui tout à
fait elle n'a pas demandé est là bon
alors demandé quand j'ai été époustouflé
de voir que le l'a fait le procès de
l'assassin du policier qui qui est le
qui a été remis en liberté je parle de
l'assassin bien sûr parce qu'ils
n'avaient pas de date d'audience 1 et
que le délai de détention étaient trop
lents n'a pas trouvé de date rapidement
et là pour marine on trouve une date
très vite non mais c'est vrai qu'il ya
des choses qui fonctionnent à des
cahiers drôle d'ambiance judiciaire
alors il aura bien lieu mais voilà elle
a réussi à créer un climat judiciaire
qui est délétère
elle c'est christiane taubira elle c'est
madame christiane taubira moi je dit
madame christiane taubira mais ni de la
justice garde des sceaux garde des
sceaux une ambiance délétère et s et une
ambiance délétère et à mon avis on va
avoir beaucoup de mal à rétablir la paix
dans la justice volonté peut-être de ne
pas interférer aussi dans les affaires
judiciaires c'est ce que défend le
projet c'est parce que c'est pas ce que
dit monsieur mélenchon l'indépendance
totale c'est ce que dit jean luc
mélenchon à ce qu'il y ait si on n'en
sait rien vraiment ça n'allait pas
renoncer
on le sera car ce pouvoir sera parti ce
que dis je cette marche ont en substance
et que le pouvoir ménagerait marine le
pen on peut vous être un très proche
je suis finalement ce serait la seule
raison de voter socialiste en 2017
que pensez vous de cette analyse mais je
pense que tout s'est tu penses que tous
ces beaux messieurs ignore ignore la la
la la la folie de l'histoire ils ne
savent pas ce que l'histoire peut
réserver savent pas personne ne le sait
personne le sait on est dans une période
climatériques on est dans une période
très difficile où les gens sont fatigués
fatigué où il ya la menace terroriste
qu'on oublie et qui hélas risque de se
rappeler à nous et à la crise économique
et le chômage
il ya aussi un mal être un sentiment de
malaise
heureusement saurait être incarnée par
marine le pen alors là on a besoin on a
besoin de bon sens et d'eau il prospère
justement sur toutes ces difficultés
même les malheurs des gens vous pouvez
pas reprocher aux bons médecins
d'accueillir les malades nous nous on
n'a jamais demandé à monsieur hollande
de faire en sorte qu'il y ait un million
de chômeurs en plus de plus sur trois
ans on n'y a pas demandé de 2,2 de créer
la contrainte pezard 500 m a demandé d
pénaliser des infractions on va pas
demander tous à nous c'est on m a
demandé de laisser filer l'autorité bon
voilà bon et que faire c'est vrai que on
est prêt à y apporter des remèdes c'est
vrai alors sur l'ordre justement manuel
valls et était dans les banlieues michel
cette semaine il a annoncé quelques
mesures je vous propose d'écouter le
premier ministre à une expérimentation
des caméras piétons elle a été
concluante
ces caméras piétons feront donc partie
de l'équipement classique des forces de
l'ordre sur le terrain c'est un élément
aussi d'abaissement voilà des caméras
des policiers équipés de caméras c'est
un élément d'apaisement on progresse
assez long pour se défendre
beaucoup mieux la caméra suit c'est
peut-être un élément n'a pas seulement
sur le terrain mais expliquez moi
comment une caméra peut être un élément
d'apaisement sur le terrain ça permet de
filmer un petit dès lors ils sont
confirmées lopez je vous signale que
c'est à la discrétion du policier que la
caméra fonctionnera vous a pas échappé
elles ont fait mieux que le récépissé
qui avaient été envisagées pour lutter
contre le consul aussi c'est aussi bête
à mon avis d'abord parce que je peux me
tromper je dirais j'avance avec avec
modestie ces mesures mais d'abord c'est
infamant pour le policier parce que ça
pose quand même une présomption de
discrimination chez le policier est
ensuite qu'est ce que tu fous rires
qu'est ce que ça apporte de ces le
policier qui va décider de filmer et
qu'est ce que ça apporte de filmer
regardez-vous états unis en mai aux
états unis la caméra des grévistes ça
empêche les crimes racistes ça empêche
la police tél pardon c'est les limites
peut-être
vous savez commission je vous connais
vous la posez leur tourne si vous ne
savez pas comment pourrais-je de savoir
j'ai une question beats on peut pas le
savoir alors sur un autre dossier que
vous connaissez certainement mieux sur
l'aide juridictionnelle elle conflit en
ce moment entre les avocats et la garde
des sceaux est ce que vous estimez que
christiane taubira entendu les avocats
puisque la réforme a été remise à plat
je constate qu elle pour qu'elle décide
d'une réforme est pour l'instant si pas
réglé et dès que les gens sont
mécontents
elle retire sa réforme bon alors encore
ce sont des réformes décidées sans
concertation sans intelligence des
situations
comment est d'accord quand même sur le
diagnostic c'est à dire que le système
est à bout de souffle et il faut faire
mieux qu'aux choses mais on veut être
comprenez on veut être généreux
c'est ça qui est friand dans ce pays ce
qu'on veut être généreux en appuis
moyens on va être bon on n'a plus les
moyens de notre bonté
on va être accueillants et on n'a plus
les moyens notre accueil il ya bien un
moment donné où on va tomber sur
l'écueil l'aide juridictionnelle le
gouvernement ou la maintenir pour ceux
qui n'ont pas les moyens et les 1000
photos ni l'effort et c'est connu les
ponts pour l'aide juridictionnelle
on la faisait gratuitement sa femme a
alors envie de payer pour moi c'était à
30 ans maintenant la mentalité a évolué
bon alors maintenant dans le comté à
pitonner c'est pas la même charge faut
être honnête
aujourd'hui la charge de l'aide
juridictionnelle elle est très lourde
il ya les gardes à vue il ya toutes les
interventions dans toutes les
juridictions
c'est pas du tout la même chose enfin la
maintenir oui ou non l'algérie où il
faut la maintenir bien sûr il faut que
le pauvre soient défendus n'est pas mêlé
faites en sorte qu' on est les moyens de
le faire
bon c'est pas en tapant drac et ses
avocats que on va financer l'aide
juridictionnelle puisque on comprend
d'un côté ce qu'on donne de l'autre
s'est passé pas c'est pas cohérent c'est
comme si on demandait aux médecins et
pourquoi les financières la sécurité
sociale ne contribuerait pas mais parce
qu'elles combinent y contribue déjà par
la charge de travail mal rémunéré 1 que
la tuerie dictionnaire leur donne parce
que c'est payé par des uv des unités de
valeurs qui sont très mal payés par
rapport au travail fourni
c'est très en dessous du vrai tarifs qui
pourrait avoir donc déjà je vous assure
quand un avocat se tape
se tape une garde à vue à minuit 1h 2h
du matin qui parle de chez lui qui va au
commissariat parfois éloignés pour
poupons pour un salaire de misère il
fait déjà une contribution bon si en
plus ça doit être prélevée sur les
comptes car pas au car sam c'est pas
juste on peut pas demander une
profession vous demandez avocat de
poursuivre la grève
et puis et puis tu écoutais on a besoin
de considération
vous nous on avale les avocats ils sont
pas considérés vous avez vu qu il aurait
traité à lille en fin quand même on a
donné l'ordre à la police de charge et
on a vu des avocats traîner à même le
pavé dans leurs robes bon c'est quand
même pas des voyous à créteil aussi à
créteil aussi bon je veux dire que bon
donc ils doivent poursuivre la guerre la
grève
il a dressé dans ce bras de fer avec
christiane taubira oui oui parce qu'il
en va
il en va de la défense ddd pauvres il en
va de la défense des pauvres vraiment
c'est très important que les pauvres
puissent être défendu gilbert collard
alors que des saisies record de cannabis
rythme en ce moment l'actualité
bruno le roux le patron des députés
socialistes a dit cette semaine
réfléchir à une évolution de la position
française sur cette question sur la
législation du deccan avis est-ce que
vous aussi vous vous seriez ouvert non
non non parce que j'ai j'ai trop vu dans
ma carrière d'avocat l'escaladent c'est
à dire l'usagé du cannabis et puis le
passage à d'autres drogues et j'ai trop
vu aussi de pauvres gens tués dans des
voitures par des conducteurs qui avaient
fumé du cannabis vous assure que si vous
avez rangé les sommations de cannabis
aujourd'hui ce n'est plus sanctionnés
que par une simple amende
c'est déjà sa vessie sanctionné cdh en
forme quand même alors tu faisais
beaucoup sanctionnés alors au boulot
entre lyon non non non mais vous voulez
et j'étais la pénalisation produit pas
des effets pervers
alors alors alors alors le voleur
condamne pas parce que ça a un effet
pervers le l'obsédé sexuel on ne
condamne pas parce que ça devait avoir
été c'est quoi ce langage qui considère
que la sanction a un effet pervers non
la sanction si elle est bien appliquée
si elle est intelligente mans appliquée
elle peut avoir un effet correctifs
sinon on baisse les bras quand on met
dans nos appartements des inscriptions
bienvenue aux cambrioleurs 1la pour y
était celle vol
merci bon là on abdique tous je veux
dire que vous serez en 2017 si marine le
pen est élue que marion ou est ce que
vous serez en 2017 si marine le pen est
élue comme le dit malek boutih devant
une coupe de champagne d'accord et
ensuite au gouvernement je sais pas ça
dépendra de marit sait ce qu'elle
souhaitera faire de nous sans prétention
nous pourrons lui ou vous êtes
disponible place vendôme à la place de
christiane taubira
c'est marine qui dit non c'est non mais
moi je suis discipliné sylvari si elle
veut m'envoyer comme ambassadeur au
vatican on verra au vatican
voilà si elle veut que je sois ministre
la justice je serai mieux de la justice
je suis là pour aider très bien dans
l'actualité il y à la réédition annoncé
de mein kampf par l'éditeur fayard dans
une version critique un travail
d'historien et que quel est votre
sentiment sur vos comptes ce choix
éditorial
je suis contre je suis content parce que
c'est alors là pour le coup pour le coup
c'est ressusciter des démons voilà peut
pas dire mieux
je dieu sait que je suis pour la liberté
d'expression le débat mais je ne sens
pas que le pays dans le contexte actuel
avec ce qu'on a pu voir lors de
certaines manifestations soit un degré
de maturité qui lui permettent de
recevoir ce livre voilà moi je ne
ressuscite pas les démons je les enferme
donc si on me demande mon avis même si
c'est entourée d'une pédagogie d'une
discussion de tout ce qu'on veut je ne
suis pas pour la la publication de ce
livre qui ressuscite les horreurs
qu'elle peut faire les pouvoirs publics
à votre nom c'est à dire une connerie
croyable
penin peut nous empêcher empêcher nation
peut empêcher la diffusion mais si on
interdit la diffusion et que et que et
que l'éditeur va jusque devant la cour
européenne
on aura tort parce que regarder ce cet
homme politique ou ce journaliste je ne
sais plus qui a condamné qui à kaka qui
a dénoncé le génocide arménien en disant
qu'ils n'existaient pas on l'a condamné
mais la cour européenne a dit que la
condamnation était infondée alors on est
là on est soumis aussi complètement aux
diktats va que la cour européenne en
appeler aux éditions fayard kilos
qu'elle revend je leur conseille
vivement de ne pas voir des conflits
machine et que son avis et l'air mais
c'est effroyable mais c'est effroyable
merci à vous d'avoir été avec de cette
semaine et la merci perrine la semaine
prochaine notre invité sera françois
bayrou bonsoir à tous et à très vite